I'm trying to move in the middle of the
water kid middle of the water mhm Island
no like you want to be on a
boat yeah nice and the only way you come
to me if the elop to flop that [__] and
grab you and come back I like that like
lit I want to live on the
water I really like this [__] like man
this [__] ain't even my playground
right
like I have my own guess [__] like
that other than that like yeah I Trav at
this house that's crazy man so for you
like cuz for people who don't know you
do you're very secluded where you are um
when you say Gravedigger Mountain like
we're literally there's a mountain you
have a mountain it's your Mountain but
for you
like secluding yourself even more is
interesting just getting a house boat
get in a yacht hey if you want to see me
these are my coordinates pull up on a
helicopter we ain't
talking I told my wife then last night
she asked me how about eat fish I say
fish she said you can't eat fish all day
yeah you can I said I get I get some
food shipped to me I guess yeah you
would have to somebody would have to bat
it to you but that's not I mean I don't
think that's uh unrealistic